.
>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG STAR
SHOW."
THINGS ARE BAD UNDER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
FROM INFLATION HOLDING AT 8.3%
TO THE UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS AT
THE BORDER WHERE BORDER PATROL
IS OVERWHELMED BY THE DRUGS AND
MIGRANTS THAT CROSS THE BORDER
EVERY CAY. -- DAY.
SO HOW COULD ANYONE SAY ANYTHING
IS PERFECT AT A TIME LIKE THIS?
A "WALL STREET JOURNAL" OP-ED
SAYS PERFECT IS THE NEW WAY TO
RESPOND TO ANYTHING.
THE, QUOTE, FEAR OF GIVING
UNINTENDED OFFENSE HAS US DOLING
OUT MACRO PRAISE FOR THE
SLIGHTEST EFFORT.
WOULDN'T THANK YOU WORK JUST AS
WELLSOME JOEY, ARE WE SO WORRIED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO OFFEND
SOMEONE OR BE CANCELED THAT NOW
WE'RE JUST GOING OVER THE TOP
WITH PRAISE OR WE DON'T WANT TO
ROCK BOAT?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
HAVE I THINK IT DEPENDS -- THAT
OP-ED TALKS ABOUT THE COLLOQUIAL
USAGE AMONG PEOPLE.
MAYBE OLDER PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
AROUND LONG ENOUGH TO KNOW
NOTHING'S PERFECT, I DON'T KNOW.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT POLITICIANS,
DON'T SPIT IN MY FACE AND TELL
ME IT'S RAINING.
DON'T TELL ME INFLATION JUST
CLIMBED UP AN INCH WHEN
YEAR-OVER-YEAR IT'S UP 8.3%.
I THINK AMERICANS FEEL THE 8
MINUTER THE .3 OR .4.
AND I THINK AMERICANS ARE IN A
PLACE NOW TO WHERE THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BELIEVE A POLITICIAN ON
A STUMP.
THEY'RE GOING TO BELIEVE WHAT
HAPPENS IN THEIR LIVES.
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
ABSOLUTELY TAKEN THE LINE OF
TELLING YOU THINGS ARE NOT WHAT
THEY SEEM AND ARE NOT AS THEY
APPEAR.
AND I THINK THEIR WORDS GET LESS
AND LESS VALUABLE NO MATTER
WHICH WORD THEY'RE USING AS THEY
CONTINUE THAT LINE AND THAT
APPROACH IN EXPLAINING AWAY
THEIR FAILURES.
>> WELL, THEY DO IT ALL THE
TIME.
AS IT RELATES TO OUR SOCIETY
THOUGH, LISTEN TO WHAT THE
AUTHOR OF THIS OP-ED ED HAD TO
SAY.
WHEN I BUY SOMETHING, THE
SALESPERSON SAYS, PERFECT.
WHEN I EXPLAIN WHEN AN
ASSIGNMENT IS DUE, THE STUDENT
SAYS PERFECT.
WHEN I RETURN A TOWEL AT THE
GYM, THE ATTENDANT SAYS PERFECT.
THE CONVENTIONAL RESPONSE IS
THANK YOU, BUT IT HAS BEEN
DISPLACED BY THIS WORD OF
ULTIMATE PRAISE.
IT IS A BY-PRODUCT OF OUR
HYPER-SENSITIVE SOCIETY WITH ITS
FEAR OF GIVING UNINTENDED
OFFENSE.
I CALL THIS MACRO PRAISE, THE
OPPOSITE OF MICROAGGRESSION.
GUY, I DON'T KNOW, IS THIS A NEW
SOCIETY IN.
>> I'M NOT SO BOTHERED BY THIS.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M GOING TO SORT OF BE --
>>
[INAUDIBLE]
>> PERFECT.
>> I'M NOT CARING.
HERE'S THE THING, I THINK PEOPLE
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT SORT OF
ROTE, RHETORICAL TICK OR TREND
WHEN SOMEONE SAYS PERFECT IN A
MINDLESS ARE WAY VERSUS WHEN
THEY MEAN PERFECTION.
I THINK WE CAN SORT OF
UNDERSTAND THE CONTEXT AND MAKE
MAKE A DIFFERENTIATION THERE.
IT REMINDS ME OF THIS THING
WHERE IF SOMEONE THANKS ME, THEY
SAY THANK YOU, AND I'LL COME
BACK WITH NO WORRIES OR NO
PROBLEM.
I'VE BEEN SCOLDED FOR THAT
SAYING JUST SAY YOU'RE WELCOME.
DON'T SAY NO WORRIES --
>> THAT'S OFFENSIVE?
>> IT'S JUST A RESPONSE.
[LAUGHTER]
LIKE, I'M JUST BEING TO POLITE.
CAN WE JUST MOVE ON WITH OUR DAY
HERE?
I REALLY DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH
THIS.
AND I THINK THAT THIS OP-ED IS,
PERHAPS, OVERTHINKING THE ISSUE
A LITTLE BIT.
>> WELL, I DO SEE THOUGH THAT
THERE IS SOME HYPERSENSITIVITY,
ALICIA, AT LEAST I FEEL LIKE IN
OUR YOUNGER GENERATION.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU AND I WERE TALKING BEFORE
THE SHOW.
MY PARENTS ARE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS.
I KNOW YOU AND YOUR FAMILY ARE
BUSINESS OWNERS AS WELL.
I THINK THAT IT'S BECOMING
INCREASINGLY HARD TO AT LEAST
CRITIQUE THE YOUNGER GENERATION
OF WORKERS BECAUSE THEY GET VERY
OFFENDED VERY EASILY.
IT SEEMS LIKE AT THE SLIGHTEST
THING.
>> FOR SURE.
AND THAT'S ANOTHER LITTLE
LANGUAGE TICK WE HAVE, FOR SURE.
>> FOR SURE.
>> THIS DOES HAPPEN.
THIS HAPPENS WITH MY HUSBAND
SOMETIMES BECAUSE HE DEALS WITH
ALL AGES OF PEOPLE WHO COME AND
WORK IN OUR RESTAURANT, AND
SOMETIMES HE'LL COMPLAIN ABOUT
SOMETHING, AND I SAY WHY TONIGHT
YOU JUST TELL THEM?
HE SAYS WE HAVE TO DO THIS TELL
CANDIDATELY BECAUSE IF THEY
AREN'T PERFECT OR GREAT, BECAUSE
IT'S NOTHING.
YOU CAN'T JUST BE OKAY AND HAVE
A NEED TO IMPROVE.
FOR SOME REASON THAT'S BECOME
VERY DIFFICULT TO APPROACH, AND
IT'S, IT'S STRANGE.
>> I'M JEALOUS, I DON'T GET TO
BRING ANY PLAINTIFF MY
COLLOQUIALISMS ONTO THE TV SET
BECAUSE MOST OF THEM AREN'T
CONSIDERED APPROPRIATE.
[LAUGHTER]
SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE I'M IN --
A BULL IN A CHINA SHOP BECAUSE
THE NUMBER O